uh this is absolutely disgusting what
i'm about to play for you
but it does remind us about the people
that donald trump had around him for so
long
donald trump's longtime advisor and
policy guy steve bannon steve bannon at
one point
sat in on the national security council
meetings
has called for the beheading of dr
anthony fauci
and of fbi director christopher wray
this was brought to my attention during
a live stream yesterday
i thought i was being baited i thought
the somebody's pulling my leg there is
no way in hell
that steve bannon said we should behead
dr anthony fauci
uh but he did he said it and steve
bannon has since been banned from
twitter i believe his show has been
banned from youtube although that's less
clear at this point take a look at this
and that's the second term second term
kicks off with firing ray
firing fouchy now i actually want to go
a step farther but i realize the
president is a kind-hearted man and a
good man i'd actually like to go back to
the old
times of tudor england i'd put the heads
on pikes
right i'd put them at the two corners of
the white house as a warning
to federal bureaucrats either get with
the program
or you're gone time to stop playing
games blow it all out but put rick
grinnell today
as the interim head of the fbi that'll
that'll light some that'll light him up
right
you know what steve just yesterday there
was the anniversary of the hanging of
two tories in philadelphia these were
quaker businessmen who
had uh cohabitated if you will with the
british while they were occupying
philadelphia
these people were hung this is what we
used to do to traitors
that's how you won the revolution nobody
wants to talk about revolution wasn't
some sort of garden party
right it was not it was a civil war it
was a civil war
remember also in the revolution you put
their heads
on pikes while you've got to remove
their heads in order to do that
steve bannon is saying behead anthony
fauci
as well as the fbi director we we behead
doctors
first of all we behead anybody but
you're going after doctors
doctors trying to deal with the pandemic
are the central target of your ire
that's what we're doing in the united
states
and as cnn business is reporting twitter
permanently suspended the account
belonging to
steve bannon after he made this
suggestion
he posted it in a video the video po
post was made to facebook youtube and
various twitter accounts
this is what we're talking about when we
talk about you al qaeda
okay um a political party
uh biden says that you need a political
party in control
that says federal employees who don't do
what they want get executed and they
also want us to believe that they are
not disgusting fascists
uh we've got a republican president
refusing to commit to a peaceful
transfer of power
insisting the election is rigged calling
on racist armed supporters to
stand by bannon talks like the taliban
and indeed right-wing extremists as i've
been pointing out for a long time
they have a lot in common with the
taliban it's just a different religion
under which they claim this outrageous
fascistic authoritarianism and remember
steve bannon has a federal indictment
against him he
is an alleged co-conspirator along with
many other republican figures close to
donald trump
and it seems to me that the consequences
should be a little more severe
severe than being banned from twitter
and this re i mean listen fauci already
has full-time security
i'm sure that the fbi director has
full-time security
uh it's not about them but it is about
again this term stochastic terrorism and
the possibility the ability that it has
to generate real world violence and in
the middle of all of this
you have a president whose son is
tweeting as we talked about earlier
we need to go to total war
total war is what they are claiming and
by the way
there's still a pandemic and i want to
talk about that a little bit